here's a nice question from the
Bangladesh mathematical Olympiad in
rectangle ABCD in the figure below a b
equals b e c d equals d f and AF equals
three units the Shaded regions have
areas X and Y with Y minus x equals 80
minus 25 Pi all over four square units
if the size of the rectangle have
integer lengths then find its area let's
break this down by symmetry this area
will be X and this area will be y so the
rectangle is equal to two quarter
circles plus two green areas minus two
blue areas the green areas are two Y and
the blue areas are 2x let this be equal
to R so the opposite side is r and this
is also R we know AF is three so the
rectangle's area is R multiplied by
three plus r and two quarter circles
will be equal to pi r squared over two
so we have the following equation we
know what y minus X is equal to from
here R is an integer so the area is an
integer so the pi terms will have to
cancel out so the area is equal to 80
over 2 which equals 40 square units